this morning I am very very pleased to  announce and excited to announce that in  fact we will be here for the next five  years correct myself Robin Fred this  deal that I have with a serious enables  us now to move really into the future  there's an excitement about an app we'll  be developing that will now include  video streaming of the show our fans  will be able to get our complete  archives you'll be able to on-demand get  everything you want audio and video wise  and then some and when I tell you what  it's going to be you're going to be very  excited about it I will be unveiling  more of this but this development of the  video aspect of our careers and the  complete archives of our careers and  everything that will be presented we  will do in conjunction with Sirius so  I'm very very excited about so there's  gonna be a video complete yes yeah yes  because that's the future don't you see